[Music]
don't do it
[Music]
so i've tried she won't come out she
won't open the door
you hit it right here
all right
air freshener at us
who you need who to come say to you
she wants her niece who's like in
california
and so last night
trying to call you by my phone i
realized
okay well ladonna they want you to leave
so i'm gonna need you to come out okay
she is banned from the property the
property owners want you to leave they
say that you're banned so if you come
out and leave
what if i don't because you won't come
out of the bathroom they want you to
leave vomiting is that a sin or a
regulation
since 11. i told you in lh for four
hours they said you've been here for
four hours well you know
too bad it doesn't open this way i know
right
no you come out and leave
i love my job
nobody's trying to kill you they want
you to leave
okay it's unlocked i can feel like the
tension from her hand just holding it
you can literally just bars through yeah
yeah once she runs out of air freshener
yeah when she runs out
holy shit
she has a lighter and aerosol spray
[Music]
it sounds like we need a supervisor this
trick is trying to set the place on fire
yes she has a lighter and aerosol spray
yeah you guys go to school
yeah exactly what we train for
yeah
if she opens that door my
so as soon as the door opens we need to
put our hands on her hands and she needs
to go
because you're trespassing
they told you to leave and you refuse to
leave and now you're trespassing and
you're trying to set the building on
fire yes you are you have a lighter an
aerosol in there and i can hear it yeah
you are not trying to save anything
it's going to be a bad time for you if
you don't open the door
it's going to be a bad time if you don't
open the door
you're gonna go in handcuffs you're
gonna go to jail
yeah oh my gosh that's right open the
door
well you're gonna go so it's gonna be a
great time
well then open the door and come out now
right now
right
[Music]
then come out okay come on
yeah right now yeah open the door
the things are gonna scare
the tasers
well she's like just christmas in there
right here
not calling anybody else you're gonna
i'm gonna kick this door down and rip
you out of there what's your son jesus
jesus
this is just what i wanted for the first
day i'm calling today god's kidding
no kidding is right right i thought it
sounded interesting so i was like right
i'm not calling nobody you're coming out
yeah it's simple for you to open the
door and come out and it's going to be a
good time when you don't
i don't even know what this lady looks
like is she whining i have no idea
no you don't get to tell me what to do
that's not how this works oh
yeah that door oh the lights are off
okay so be hey so once burns gets here
the lights are okay
[Music]
we haven't sprayed anything yet but
we're fixing to you have your pepper
spray
he has his pepper spray so we're going
to spray the door right now under the
door
um we're going to go from there
because she keeps spraying she has a
lighter so she's trying to set us on
fire you know
no i started driving
right before you show you you need to go
okay
we can but we were going to try to we
could convert it down
let's bust it down and then spray oh
open the door so the light is off so we
need to be aware of that okay okay
so
the light is off okay she has a lighter
she has the spray
i'm gonna come out
come on right
now here
no come out no i need that okay so
we're you ready we're gonna rip your
hands off we're gonna see it or bust
open
oh that's open i don't see that go see
her bust it up and then i was here yeah
we have a crack
that goes in right it goes in yeah so
when we're going to hit her okay so
let's play gonna bust the thin spider
we're going to bust it and then go
handle them
because we have to go hands-on she's
already like okay so let's just go
hands-on enough
[Music]
yep
you're hurting me okay i'll go to jail i
don't mind i don't want it started
give a shirt now
on my phone that is so nasty yeah this
one's unnecessary you're right we don't
have to do any of this i'm sorry i'm
really just okay oh shit let's keep the
black
let's play the blood of him
this is not right it's not right it's
really not my brain
yep
this is not right
[Music]
why are you taking my rooms
why
i don't understand
wait why are you doing this to me why
are you doing this to me oh that's cute
after all that that's cute
who was she isn't she like in cartoons
or something oh yeah yeah who is that
what's your name
what's her name uh hot daphne
[Music]
when i was only
[Music]
stop moving don't grab him don't go
grabbing you don't grab me i'm not
grabbing you don't put your hands curl
your hands don't grab it like this okay
don't move your arms okay
can i have something on my cheeks or you
dropped her dasty you dropped it i did
do you want her
yeah
that was one of my favorites
it was yeah it's a good one it is a good
can you just stick it on my chest over
here under happiness oh that would be
cool wouldn't it you're not okay
you're on a cage
what's wrong biggie what's wrong huh
okay would you put jason